you know the Beatles have been on my
mind lately because we did a week last
week in tribute to George Harrison and
and working with his son Danny and I I
found out today because I was doing some
research that that back in the 60s John
Lennon and Ringo Starr we're trying to
urge you to become a pop star is that
correct I did a show in Little Theatre
in the north of England called a
smashing day in for which I wrote the
songs and sang them as a musical
narrator that sort of chorus that came
on and told the audience what was
happening and Brian Epstein who was the
manager of the Beatles then saw the show
took everyone no took nobody from the
cast to London recast it in London but
took the singer and the song that was me
and we had an opening night very
thrilling my first night on a London
stage and John Lennon and Ringo Starr
were in the audience because of Brian
and I met them not backstage
dressing-room but backstage in the
auditorium sort of under the exit sign
they were both standing there by the red
velvet curtains as it were and they said
noise as well because I thought it was
alright I think I've just been flattered
as yeah yeah anyway they said you know
you should see our Dick James who's the
manager of northern songs and you should
talk about singing career and I did he
had a desk larger than yours that's not
possible
and I sat there listening to the great
dick James blow cigar smoke all over me
and tell me about my and my mind drifted
off and I thought you won't hack it you
won't do it won't make it so I went into
classical theatre instead but I do have
a musical aircon and it helps you with
my accents with changing character with
you know I do
I do love discovering the musical rhythm
inside a person
one's rhythm is different and if I can
hit on that rhythm it unlocks a part of
the physical and vocal energy of the
character it has to be connected to
music I mean the way you perform though
the the as you said the voices you do
and the notes that you hit with people
yeah it has to be it has to come from a
musical part of you and also after
seeing dick James behind his enormous
desk
I was then invited to join the Royal
Shakespeare Company and that is like
singing opera it's a cat ordinary yeah
and it's very very accessible it's very
tangible it's very real so you're
dealing with very real flesh and blood
issues but but but conveying them
through the most beautiful musical
poetic language that I guess my first 10
years were with them so if I want in
repertoire I could be playing a comedy
on Monday night and a tragedy on Tuesday
night an historical play on Wednesday
night III I varied at night by night so
much that by the time it came to my film
career god bless it god bless it I I was
able to move perhaps a little more
adroitly than than perhaps if I was
shoved into a corridor and never played
Shakespeare I thank Shakespeare for so
much of my career
you